Nobody likes a bad movie, but nobody hates a
flop any more than the stars themselves. Whip out
some rotten tomatoes, because these major movie
stars got defensive over their box office bombs.
It's no surprise that Hollywood's always
been enamored with the tale of Robin Hood.
A do-gooder who battles a tyrannical villain to
help the less fortunate, Robin Hood is a medieval
superhero — but reimagining folk tales as gritty
action movies seems like a bit of a tired idea.
"Really inspiring. Thanks."
So in 2018, when Robin Hood hit theaters
starring Taron Egerton as the bow-wielding
rogue, it bombed at the box office. But
in the aftermath of the movie's failure,
Egerton was quick to throw blame
and defend his part in the film.
In an interview with Variety, Egerton claimed,
"It was absolutely not the movie that I signed up
to make. It was pitched to me in a different way."
What that way could have been we're not
sure, but perhaps they left the dark,
gritty reboot part out when selling him
on the film. Whatever the case may be,
the star believed the film's problems
boiled down to excessive studio meddling.
"What are you doing?"
"My duty, Loxley.
We have new orders from above. Like it or
not, soldier, we're all powerless here."
Egerton explained what he
thought happened, saying,
"I think it was made by committee
and I think it lost its vision. I
wasn't very happy on set. I didn't
have a very happy time making it."
Arguably one of the most infamous comic book
flops, 2004's Catwoman started out in the 1990s
as a spin-off featuring Michelle Pfeiffer's
character from Batman Returns. But after years
in development hell, actress Halle Berry took
over the role. A critical and box office bomb,
the film took home a number of "worst"
awards at the Razzies the following year.
"White Russian. No ice. Hold
the vodka, hold the Kahlua."
Regardless, star Halle Berry has never been
ashamed of this one, even showing up in person
to collect her "Worst Actress" Razzie.
In fact, she's always defended the film,
and had plenty to say about it in response to
its harshest critics, telling the Daily Mail,
"It was definitely different from any
other [movie] I had seen. I thought that
we needed a better villain, but
I was outnumbered in that area."
Like Egerton on Robin Hood,
Berry also talked about the
struggles of assessing a project
even after it's produced, saying,
"You just never know how people are going
to respond. [For example] I thought that
Monster's Ball was going to end my career.
And look what happened. You just never know."
You never know is right: Berry took home an
Academy Award for her work in Monster's Ball.
If Catwoman was the biggest comic book movie bust
of the 2000s, Morbius is its 2020s successor.
Centered on the titular vampire anti-hero played
by Jared Leto, Morbius was savaged by critics,
becoming the butt of jokes that helped
fuel long-running Internet memes.
But despite the negative reaction
and lack of box office bucks,
Matt Smith, who played the movie's
villain, didn't let it get him down.
"I will not go back. You cannot make me
go back. I won't let you make me go back."
The former Doctor Who star told Rolling Stone,
"It was thrown under the bus. But you just have
to roll with it. What else are you gonna do?"
Unwilling to be dragged
down by the film's failure,
Smith insisted that everything be put in
the proper perspective. He elaborated,
"It's a film, at the end of the day, we're
not saving lives. For whatever reason,
it didn't quite work out and – It is what it is."
Can we really call Black Adam a bomb? It certainly
wasn't the hit studio execs were expecting,
not even pulling in $400 million on a reported
$200 million dollar budget. Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever amassed more domestically
in just three days than Black Adam did in
its entire run — and the DC film fell
to fourth place in less than 30 days.
But Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson got defensive
at the mere suggestion that his movie
compared unfavorably to Wakanda Forever, its
major rival at the box office. He tweeted —
"There's no competition with the established
global brand of Black Panther compared to Black
Adam & JSA who a year ago no one even heard
of. [...] We're new babies and have to grow."
"There is no 'we' here. There are
only heroes, and there are villains."
Meanwhile, when Variety outright called the film
a bust, Johnson pushed back on Twitter, saying,
"Our film will PROFIT [...] we are
building our new franchise step by step."
Not long after, Johnson reportedly leaked
a misleading financial statement to refute
claims of the film losing money — an unusual
tactic for a major star to say the least.
Cats was a celebrated Tony Award-winning Broadway
musical. That it wasn't adapted to film until 2019
is actually somewhat surprising. It would have
made a delightful Disney animated movie. Instead,
audiences got a live-action retelling starring the
likes of Judi Dench, Ian McKellan, Taylor Swift,
and Idris Elba, all digitally dolled-up as
bizarre anthropomorphic human-cat hybrids.
Critics and audiences were baffled and
horrified in equal measure, and the film
was a major disaster all the way around. But
the cast never wavered — Jennifer Hudson,
who played Grizabella in the film,
was particularly defensive in the
face of harsh critical response. In a 2021
interview with Total Film, Hudson said,
"You know what? I think it was a bit
overwhelming. It's unfortunate that
it was misunderstood. I think later down
the line, people will see it differently."
But whether the film improves with age or remains
a misfire, Hudson has no regrets, claiming,
"It is something I am still very
proud of and grateful to have been
a part of. Yeah, I got to be
Grizabella the Glamour Cat!"
In the late 2000s, sci-fi and fantasy franchises
were delivering blockbuster box office returns,
and Disney wanted to kickstart one of their own.
"Carter. John Carter."
In 2012, the studio released the ill-fated
flop John Carter. It was slammed by critics
for its confusing story, incoherent
plot, and nonsensical characters,
becoming one of the biggest box
office disasters of the 2000s.
If anyone had reason to be angry, it would be
Taylor Kitsch, who played the titular Carter.
But despite all the derision the movie
received and the money the film lost,
Kitsch maintained that it
wasn't a flop at all, saying,
"I don't see it as a failure,
that's the thing. I'm incredibly proud
of it and I would do it all over again."
Pointing out that the film still
sold plenty of tickets, Kitsch added,
"If someone told me that my first lead film
will make well over 300 million
dollars, that's a good thing."
But the actor was most defensive
about his own role in the film,
insisting any shortcomings had
nothing to do with him. He alleged,
"I know personally I literally did
everything possible I could have in John
Carter. [...] That's why I prep so hard, and why
I push myself so hard, so I can have no regrets."
Another notorious money pit, Gigli, was a romantic
crime thriller from 2003 starring Ben Affleck
and Jennifer Lopez, about a pair of crooks who
screw up a kidnapping plot. Affleck and Lopez
began dating during production, which prompted the
studio to rewrite the script. The movie ended up
being a total disaster, earning back a fraction
of its budget and getting roasted by critics.
"In every relationship, there's
a bull and a cow. I'm the bull.
You're the cow. You got that?"
Affleck blamed the studio for playing up the
publicity around their real-life romance,
telling Entertainment Weekly,
"Because I had begun having this relationship
with Jennifer Lopez, which was selling a lot
of magazines and appeared to generate a lot of
enthusiasm, they just predictably latched onto,
'They want a romantic comedy. They want
the two of them together. More of that!'"
But Lopez went further, openly admitting
that the film sucked. In an appearance on
Late Night with Seth Meyers, Lopez
got a bit defensive when pressed.
"There's worse movies than 'Gigli' out there, OK?"
But Lopez, like Affleck, admitted that
their relationship, which was getting
all the attention during filming, was
at least part of the film's problem.
"I know! I know! We got a lot of crap at that time. It was because
we were together. It was a whole
other thing going on as well."
Adapted from the iconic TV series, The
Lone Ranger was thought to be the next
big franchise for Disney and Johnny Depp,
who'd had blockbuster success with Pirates
of the Caribbean. Lone Ranger was anything but
a blockbuster, however, losing an estimated $200
million. But that didn't seem to bother the film's
stars, Johnny Depp and Armie Hammer, who brushed
off any suggestion that the movie had failed.
In an interview with Yahoo! Movies, Depp said,
"I think the reviews were written
seven-to-eight months before we
released the film. I think the reviews were
written when they heard Gore [Verbinski] and
Jerry [Bruckheimer] and me were going to do
The Lone Ranger. They had expectations that
it must be a blockbuster. I didn't have
any expectations of that. I never do."
"I'm a spirit warrior. I can't miss."
Hammer, meanwhile, was more feisty in
his defense of the film, asserting that,
"If you go back and read the negative reviews,
most of them aren't about the content of the
movie, but more what's behind it. It's got
to the point with American critics where if
you're not as smart as Plato, you're stupid.
That seems like a sad way to live your life."
Hammer believes the press piled on
in a critical feeding frenzy, adding,
"I think it was the popular thing
when the movie hit rocky terrain
they jumped on the bandwagon to try and bash it."
Although the thriller Serenity boasted
a stellar cast, it launched in 2019 to
little fanfare. In addition to stars
Matthew McConaughey and Anne Hathaway,
it also featured Diane Lane,
Jason Clarke, Djimon Hounsou,
and Jeremy Strong. The film tells the story of
a divorced boat captain who reluctantly comes to
the aid of his ex-wife when she wants to have
her abusive husband taken out of the picture.
"I want you to take him out on your boat
and drop him in the ocean for the sharks."
Unfortunately, the movie failed to connect with
critics or audiences and didn't
even make back its modest budget.
But Hathaway wasn't deterred by the
film's poor critical or commercial
reception and took to social media
to defend her work. She posted:
"We keep it real around here. Some critics get
Serenity and, like me, find it interesting,
moving, ambitious and different, and for
some it just doesn't work. That's cool."
"Sometimes we do bad things for good reasons."
Hathaway appeared to accept that
not everyone has to like a project,
but her defense was more than just
a fair-minded retort. In fact,
the actress seemed to take personal
offense to the bad reviews, writing,
"There is no failure, only learned events, not
everyone has to like everything, and the critical
response doesn't change my feelings about the
movie. However, other people's time and money are
not to be taken for granted, so I just want to be
clear: I endorse the movie, many critics don’t."
Produced by Judd Apatow, Bros is a romantic
comedy written by and starring comedian Billy
Eichner. It focuses on two men who are decidedly
not looking for commitment, but nevertheless
fall in love. Despite praise for its LGBTQ
cast including Luke Macfarlane, Ts Madison,
and Eichner himself, the film bombed at the
box office. But unlike most flops on this list,
Bros received critical acclaim for its clever
comedy, earnest story, and heart. As a result,
Eichner was more than just disappointed
by the film's take at the ticket counter,
as he lashed out at both critics and at
audiences while defending its failure.
In some since-deleted Twitter
comments, Eichner put the blame on
homophobic audiences who refused to show
up for the well-reviewed film, tweeting:
"Straight people, especially in
certain parts of the country,
just didn't show up for Bros. Everyone who ISN'T
a homophobic weirdo should go see Bros tonight."
"Lesbian history month was in
March. Nobody said a goddamn thing."
But despite his emotional outburst, Eichner
did make a few valid points, writing,
"Rolling Stone already has BROS
on the list of the best comedies
of the 21st century. What's also true is
that at one point a theater chain called
Universal said they were pulling the
trailer because of the gay content."
Although the studio convinced the
theater to continue running the trailer,
evidence suggests that we still
have a long way to go before LGBTQ
content is completely accepted and
celebrated by the American moviegoer.